hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
finally finally finished construction of
my castle on the island and it may not
seem like much it may not seem like I've
done all that much from last time but
let me tell you I have worked way too
long to try to get this thing in
glorious working order
as you can see power is no longer a
problem
I've got unlimited power panels
supplying my spotlights which hopefully
will allow me to be rescued at some
point in my life they're gonna come and
help me when I'm alone on this island
but until that day comes I have to
entertain myself so please come on into
my home as you can see remember how the
plants wanted to be in my base anyway I
just kind of rolled with it because if
they're gonna be in here I might as well
fill the rest of it in I've got plants
on the walls plants in the pots plants
in the garden I've got lots and lots of
hanging fruit tree I never ever ever
need to worry about food again I've got
so much food
let's amounts of food perfect for going
exploring in the giant empty ocean that
is my life so as we move up through the
different levels you'll see just in case
I don't want to go into the ocean to
find my fish friends who just so
happened to be my only friends and the
only ones that'll keep me warm at night
but I keep them here in my aquariums
where I just look at them and watch them
as they wallow in misery at their
isolation from their home because that's
something that we can relate on our
crushing loneliness now speaking of
crushing loneliness in the next room we
have what I call the friendship room
every time I make a new friend on this
island I'm gonna put their picture on
the wall and then make sure they sit in
the chair forever so that we can hang
out and laugh
laughing it'll happen eventually someday
someday okay and in the next room we
have the fabrication stuff because when
you had a lot of friends and we're all
moving in and out of the house eating
all my food laughing at all my jokes
hang an apple with me sharing a bed
together
you know you don't want to crowd one
fabricator I'm planning for the future
here so plenty of stuff to be used here
now this this is my thinking room I'd
like to I like to keep this one
generally very isolated from the other
rooms because it's pretty bare-bones
because when I'm thinking to this room I
don't really have anything other than my
own thoughts to keep me company so I
just kind of like to keep it the way it
is and then I go up to the next room
which is another one of my friendship
rooms and speaking of which it's nothing
but lockers so I have new names to put
on the lockers which are over there I
can't hear where okay so the first name
going on the brand new lockers directly
away from the ladder if I was coming out
there the first one goes to rainbow
chipmunk so rainbow shipment there we go
good enough who said Wow mark that's the
most planning you've ever done and I had
to look and all I did was talk about a
potted plant so thank you for having so
much faith in me and low expectations I
have the same things about myself and
the next one goes to Jill Kay who
commented that in every game that I ever
play and I am my own worst enemy that in
doorways so thank you very much and then
Jay Pyrus j'ai pris pep pyre Pyrus who
reminded me that even though I don't
have Wilson companioning me me me I have
Karen my computer wife who is going to
be with me throughout all eternity in my
solitude on this island anyway also
Connor mark so Connor mark who said
markiplier can you find the lifepod Rex
which is actually something that I want
to do and I have a list here because
there
many of you may have asked yourself
throughout this game why aren't there
any other survivors and the fact of the
matter is there were there were other
jettisoned life pods but as you could
see when coming into the atmosphere for
some reason they all blew up even minded
mine blew up I was able to put out the
fire I got knocked out right in the head
but I was able to put out the fire oh by
the way that's a new intro sequence that
you guys haven't seen yet let me play
that right now for you it's really cool
so Bing
Oh anyway so that's not good so now the
game actually does start I'm just gonna
roll into this because whatever right Oh
thumping bass alright so then you pick
up this poured out the fire first spray
it up to the left because if you feel
like it in your badass pretty cool right
so when you start a new game in
subnautica that's what you see and it
kind of gives an explanation of the
panic coming out of there and just
imagine other life pods that you know
we're leaving the ship as well but they
didn't make it and we're gonna go to
them but I have just a few more things
to show you in my lovely home my castle
on an island all by myself so this is
the top floor and obviously there's not
a lot going on here it became harder and
harder to build out as I went farther up
but over here I have another aquarium
and these are called whole fish as you
can see they're solid and oh my god are
they all dead holy [ __ ] that's
horrifying they weren't like that when I
first put them in there but they look
very dead but the reason that I filled
it with exclusively whole fish is
because much like me they have a hole
inside them that can never be filled
anyway and the final thing the coup de
Gras of this entire castle is my
observation chamber where I can sit in
this chair and watch the moon go by if
you can even call that a moon because
there's a separate thing that's actually
also a moon here that's just another
planet that's orbiting ah there it is
it's kind of a weird double moon
situation that's actually really pretty
look at that look at that and that is
actually they're not fooling anybody
I think that's Earth's moon they're just
judging by the graphic of it but anyway
so that is my castle the crushing
loneliness eats away at me at the
darkest of nights ignore that I wasn't
done building anyway so the next thing
that we're gonna do is we're actually
going to go to these ship pods but I'm
gonna wait until daytime because it's
gonna suck to be in the middle of the
ocean at
Knight and I need to get my seamoth
anyway so I need to go back down to my
water base where am i seamoth is
conveniently stored I'm gonna take a few
of these for the road just in case oh
isn't that a lovely light show see no
one could miss this if anyone was flying
by in a nearby galaxy it's a party they
know someone has fun here by themselves
thank you Karen I've missed you hope
you've been good I am going to go on an
adventure to find the corpses of my
fallen comrades
I forgot I've got another way but
there's a weird thing here if I go down
one for some reason the ocean doesn't
quite clear out on this level but it
just transitions down here and then it's
air again first some bizarre reason I
have no idea why that is that way so now
I got my seamoth and now I'm gonna go
with the [ __ ] duck and we're gonna go
find us some cake but to be a little bit
easier I'm just gonna use work demands
because I would have to like finagle II
find them and I don't want to do that
because even though they're generally
easy to find areas I'm going to show you
exactly where they are right now well
that didn't work why didn't that work
can I not be in my seemeth when I do
that let me try that without I'm gonna
suck without but I don't even have my
yeah I can make it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
cool all right so it's gotta be around
here I forgot you're here oh hey buddy
don't don't even think about it bro
don't don't don't don't no naught noot
noot noot do it that's right you better
back off okay
so just about where are we looking at
here
oh god I'm out of air I forgot my air
tank oh [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up where was it I was
supposed to have spawned right on top of
it
oh no is that one of the new features
that's not in my game just barely made
it right at the crack of dawn thank you
very much see the unfortunate thing is
that the next time that I play this game
I actually oh it's not here is it oh my
god it's not oh dang it is it not here
crap okay
so I was wondering what was going on see
the thing is I've been playing this one
saved game for so long that I actually
see yeah I would have found that
immediately that's my original base like
that's my base there if it was here I
would have found it so what happened is
I've been playing this particular game
for so long and they've done so many
updates to the game that the terrain
they've upgraded my save game but I've
actually been excluded from some of the
more pertinent things in the game so I'm
gonna start a new game here real quick
and then I'm gonna show you these things
I'm not gonna not show you these things
I've got to show you these things okay
so we're back this is now the
experimental mode which has new updates
new updates coming out for the game
every few days instead of waiting for
about a month in between each one so
this means that save games gets invalid
all the time but this means also that
new features get put out as they're made
and they're made all the time so with
that so the reason why we're here is
we're gonna find these escape pods which
is going to be dangerous because I don't
have much air but that doesn't matter
cuz we're gonna be fine
alright so warping to the first one and
as you'll see when we get here whoopsie
doop see I can't see [ __ ] there we go
once we get here ah-ha there it is it
just wasn't in my game because my game
was so old so as you can see someone was
here but where the chair is there
there's nothing out on the other side
literally this guy just didn't make it
so somewhere in here I believe there's
there should be anyway there should be
like a PDA from the person who was here
but I can't seem to find it I know god
is so far away I'm not gonna make it I
don't have an o2 tank god damn it oh
it's gonna be close so this is the first
one and I don't see the PDA anywhere
here but that doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist but it just means that I
can't find it in this particular one
maybe it's in there maybe it's uh maybe
I can find it if I dig around the sand
but whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa where'd my
knife go I had a knife Hey alright so
now we're gonna go to the next 150 so
now we're going to the second pod which
is in the safe shallows right here so as
you can see like there there are a total
of seven separate pods I only have the
coordinates for six of them but they're
all here and they all tell their own
story about these poor people that just
did not make it it really sucks like it
really sucks let me try to let me get
the scanner but anyway I dug through the
sand as best I could I could not find a
PDA which it said that there was but
apparently that is not the case I really
hope this doesn't warp me very close to
that rora because it's about to be all
okay it's a mere first hello everybody
most of these are actually in the safe
shallows so they're in places where
things are generally okay Wow this one
just obliterated holy crap was this
actually one of them oh my god it
couldn't have there's a vending machine
holy [ __ ] I don't have to eat dirty
alien fish anymore holy crap
ah that's so weird that is one of them
yeah wow that pod just got obliterated
how would anyone even know that it was a
pod
I don't think this was a pod this this
seems like a fast-food restaurant and
that makes even less sense than the
other one
why did this just explode whoa there we
go
whoo that one's like illuminated by the
creep vines I didn't even know those
glowed I don't think those used to
global god that's so cool I mean
building an island base is one thing but
I am too close to that aren't I well
[ __ ]
this might be bad for me hmm I should
move maybe I'll do it I don't know could
be who knows
well [ __ ] good cool beans for me oh well
that's not good
I forgot that radiation was kind of a
problem but I need to see if there's
something in here and what's weird is
that all of these pods - the ones that
were completely obliterated seem to have
damage in the same exact way as all the
other ones which is mostly just one of
the seats getting ripped away which I'm
assuming means that they did not survive
that they unfortunately didn't sit in
the right seat like I did and they were
caught unawares and the Reaper Leviathan
is out there I don't know I'm still in
the radiations oh [ __ ]
damn this is another one that just
obliterated I don't even know are there
are there PDAs that are supposed to be
around here this is a robotics arm is it
oh wait there's a locker that's a locker
let me let me see about that one [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] gonna die gonna die need to
check the locker hang on oh [ __ ] it's
gonna be one please tell me hello who
are you
I've seen this picture before she's
beautiful well I've got a different
problem I I think I'm gonna die which is
great I've never died a radiation before
alright so in the future it says that in
the future there will be PDS but this
answers the age-old question of where
the hell are all the other people that
were on this ship and I am dead yeah
there we go
whoo yeah yeah that felt bad okay oh let
me do this you've been down too long in
the midnight sea oh don't you see what I
mean no I don't see what you mean creepy
message I have no idea what you're
talking about
so anyway that is all the time that I
have for subnautica in this episode hope
you enjoyed my castle which is in a
different save game and hope you enjoyed
this one in the next video
since I'm in experimental mode I can
actually show you
the Emperor Leviathan and the other
giant monstrosity and I will get to that
in the next episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always see you in the next video